I didn't say they couldn't do it.
I said it was a bad idea.
Okay.
Okay,
so you don't have,
well I think,
I think that Dave,
I really do believe,
and I'm sad about this,
I do believe that they've bitten off more
than they can chew and then it's going
to be,
it's,
it's one small,
it's a,
it's a warning side with regards to
these media conglomerates that are
attempting to produce large scale public
discourse because now they've taken on,
they've taken the role of sensor
onto themselves and they'll find it.
That's a never ending role
that produces endless trouble.
They've got themselves into endless
trouble as far as I'm concerned.
And for as it from a perspective
of a clinical psychologist,
I would also say the worst thing you
can do to someone who's paranoid,
the most ill advice thing you can do
to someone who's paranoid is persecute
them.
So now that,
I mean Alex Jones is always talking
about if the little I know about him,
he's always talking about are
conspiracies of one form or another.
And now what has all the appearance of
a conspiracy between four or five very
large media conglomerates
is aimed squarely at him.
So all the people who are watching him
who are conspiracy minded and somewhat
paranoid are going to think,
well,
Jones must be onto something because
otherwise these big conglomerates wouldn't
have clamped down on him.
That's a very,
very bad idea.
And millions of people watch him.
So these holes,
well thought,
these are people who thought that Podesta
had an unheard sex ring in a pizza
parlor.
So I don't really think that this is
necessarily the straw that broke the
camel's back.
Um,
it sounds to me,
so I want to make sure that clarify.
Are you not amongst the
people who believe that,
uh,
these big platforms like youtube,
Facebook should be treated
like public utilities?
Because there are a lot of right
wingers who do believe that like phone,
yeah,
I think they should be treated as public
utilities because otherwise they can't
exist because there's no possible way
that these corporations can handle
monitoring that they're content.
There's too much content.
So they'll run,
they'll run out of manpower
to make the decisions.
I mean now what,
okay,
so Alex Jones is now being banned.
What do you think about people
who've interviewed Alex Jones,
should they be banned?
That would include Joe Rogan for example.
Cause he interviewed Alex Jones.
Yeah.
So it should be banned him.
Well and if not,
why not?
So you think that Facebook,
youtube,
Google,
these companies that,
you know,
basically startup in garages,
these tech startups and invest millions
of dollars and they grow to become
successful and then you
support the government stepping
in and an authoritarian
fashion and telling them who they
have to allow on their platforms.
I didn't say the
government should step in.
I said that they made a
mistake by deciding to act
as sensors and that they'll
pay for it.
I didn't say anything about anybody
stepping in and changing it.
I said it was a mistake.
Well if they're to be treated like
public utilities and that would be the
government stepping in
cause right now they're not.
Well if they were to be
treated as public utilities,
that would be a transformation
in the way they were regulated.
So that really doesn't have anything
to do specifically with the Alex Jones
issue.
Don't support it.
You would support it.
Okay.
And that's the question because I'm
the one having to come up with all the
complex answers.
All right,
so how would you propose that
these complex corporations
decide which content is
acceptable?
Exactly.
How would you propose specs?
I don't think there does
need to be a proposal.
I mean I think this is where
actually I would be on your side.
Let the free market decide and the free
market is youtube and Facebook and if
they don't want to host content,
I don't think they should
be forced to host content.
I don't think they should be
compelled to host content.
Well obviously they shouldn't be that.
That's not the issue.
The issue is how are they going to go
about making the decisions and how are we
going to be sure that that
won't go dreadfully wrong?
I mean,
obviously it's the case that
censorship can go wrong.
You certainly see that
in places like China.
Once you start with censorship,
how do you know?
How do you have any idea?
How are you going to put proper boundaries
around it and decide who's acceptable
you're,
they're going to let your listeners decide
that or you're going to decide it and
then you're going to find out that
you've taken on a huge weight of decision
making that you can't handle.
Or maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe that won't happen,
but it's certain.
Certainly I would be very low to decide
what needs to be censored because the
number of decisions I'd have to
make with multiplied beyond end.
Well,
I'm not saying what any
specific individual does.
I'm saying,
let the free market decide.
If people don't want a
Alex Jones on Youtube,
then youtube doesn't have to provide it.
If people watching youtube,
I already agreed that youtube
doesn't have to provide it.
I said it was a mistake
to engage in censorship.
Sure.
Just because people are allowed to do
something doesn't mean it isn't a mistake
upon occasion.
So I'm not asking for
government regulation and the
idea that transforming these
corporations into something approximating
utilities would be a form of
regulation is really an and,
and what would you say it's an ill
formed way of posing the question.
It's a matter of classification.
Do you think that Alex Jones
should be able to use a phone?
I do think Alex Jones to be able to
use a phone as long as he pays for it,
as long as the phone company
wants to offer him their services.
Right.
So the phone company offers everyone
equal access to the services regardless of
content.
And I presume you to object if the
phone service started to decide that
conversation shouldn't
be allowed to occur.
And so it it,
you can make a reasonable argument that
these large scale media distribution
companies played the same role.
But on a larger scale.
It's not necessarily the case that
it's an argument without flaw,
but it's a reasonable argument.
But I don't think that
there's any real alternative.
I don't see how companies like Facebook
and Youtube can possibly police their
content without producing far
more trouble then they'll save.
That's the issue.
Well,
I'm not so much just concerned about the,
in the content.
What I'm concerned with
is let's say we did it.
So the public utilities sort of option,
right?
Um,
what I'm concerned with is the free market
will be able to provide alternatives.
You know,
Alex Jones can go there if we believe,
if we're consistent and we believe in
freedom of speech and the freedom of
market as it applies thereof,
we should be free to accept,
we should believe follow this
down the logical trail that a,
there'll be an alternative
platform for Alex or no?
Yes,
there probably will be.
And that's also why I think it was a
mistake for these companies engage in the
censorship because I think that they're
signing their own death warrant by doing
so.
It will probably take 10 years to unfold.
But it's a big mistake.
And so that is what will happen is because
people will stop trusting youtube and
Facebook.
And so forth to provide
uncensored access to content.
And as a consequence,
other forms of,
of information distribution will emerge.
So it's,
that's why I thought it was bad
decision from corporate perspective.
They had every right to make it,
but I think it's bad decision,
right?
If I were to,
if I were to walk into your house,
okay,
if I were to walk into your house right
now and just and harass you and call you
all sorts of names and get right up in
your face and not leave after you've
asked me to leave and
continue harassing you,
uh,
without any,
any,
a refuge for you,
would you think that that is
a crime for me to do that?
I don't know why you're
asking the question.
So let me tell you why that's,
so now again,
this is why we were talking
about the constitution in guns.
Now I have fully automatic air
fifteens and things change,
right?
Times change,
we need to adapt.
And we've both agreed
on that to some extent.
Now Online,
people like Alex Jones,
they have the ability to invade your
house digitally continually and harass and
berate shut off.
Not necessarily.
That's the thing.
You can't,
you can't shut off everything.
You can't block people.
He can't mute people on every platform.
Then they can have your email on youtube.
You,
you know,
it shows up in your suggested for the
point is as fast as you can just shut the
whole thing off if you want.
So it's a silly argument.
It's not like someone invading your house.
So because you can shut
it off at any time.
Okay.
It's just not,
that's just not going anywhere.
That argument.
Well,
what if someone has a computer in their
house then if they have a computer now
son,
it means that someone can invade their,
their house that way digitally.
There's,
there's no way to find
a space away from me.
Particularly people like Alex Jones,
most egregious offenders,
right.
Who spread conspiracies and effectively
like lead to doxing of people.
Um,
I mean
the thing is too,
it's again,
again the,
the,
the question is more fundamental.
Let's assume that it's a bad idea for
poorly supported conspiracy theories to be
formulated and distributed.
Let's assume that,
yeah,
fine.
Well,
we don't need to put it in air quotes.
We could probably both assume it.
The question is what should you
do with people who are doing that?
And that one answer is well,
do what you can to silence them
and drive them underground.
The other is let them talk and let
people make up their own minds.
And my sense is,
is that people are wise enough to listen
to people of that sort and decide that
that's too extreme.
Now,
not every one,
because
conspiracy theorists can find followers
among people who are disagreeable and
somewhat paranoid,
but it's best for everyone,
including the conspiracy
theorists themselves,
that those things are aired in public
discussion because it helps keep people
saying,
you know,
like I've known people who
are a little bit on this.
Disagree.
Yeah,
but that's because you don't
know what you're talking about.
I have no incorrect.
Listen,
there are more Americans
who believe in angels
then in climate change,
uh,
the top shows that are Kardashians.
Look at what's on television.
I don't believe that the American public,
that anyone should be granted the same.
Yeah.
And as you see that they should be,
there should be,
why should treat them wise enough?
I'm saying I don't think they're wise
enough and that's why the compared to the
alternatives.
Okay.
You know,
your system in the United States was never
set up under the presumption that the
people were wise.
It was set up under the
presumption that the people,
regardless of their wisdom,
had the right to self determination.
And even more importantly that although
the people themselves might not always
be wise,
there isn't a better source of
authority than the people themselves.
So that no matter how corrupt and
foolish the people happen to be,
whatever systems you put in place
to supplant them will be worse.
And so I think,
and you might not believe that,
but that,
and that's fine,
but that is the founding
principal of the dark blue.
I don't believe it.
Yeah,
that's fine.
You don't believe it.
Don't believe that.
I don't believe that Alex Jones
and anyone with a Facebook page is,
for example,
as qualified and a,
and as I say for the American public as
Walter Cronkite or people in the Senate
and house who are qualified
to make these determinations.
I don't,
that's just a disagreement,
but I'll let people,
you know,
let's switch just a diff disagreement.
It's actually a disagreement about the
fundamental structure of the entire
political system because you'd think
that it's possible to produce banks of
experts of one sort or another who can
supplant the fundamental will of the
people.
And I don't think,
I think that that's a very bad idea.
And I think that history
shows that that's a bad idea,
at least with democracy itself
tends to be self correcting.
So if people make egregious errors,
they correct them in the next election.
Well,
okay,
sorry.
I want to,
I want to give you a quote.
So again,
that is self authoring.com if you want
to take your quiz and the book 12 rule
for life is available at places.
Um,
so let me,
uh,
final question.
Do you ever,
does it ever concern you that you
might be on the wrong side of history?
Okay.
What mostly concerns me is whether
I make a mistake when I'm talking.
And so I,
I,
I'm not thinking about the
wrong side of history precisely.
So
I might be making mistakes
that concerns me all the time.
But,
um,
I thought most,
I thought the things that I say
through very carefully and you know,
I'm perfectly willing
to live or die by them,
let's say.
So,
um,
well I asked you that,
cause you know,
we've gone through a litany of,
of,
you know,
using people's preferred pronouns
of the idea of compassion,
um,
neither of which do you support.
And then we've gone through things like
Alex Jones and extremists and social
media and these are ideas that you do.
I wonder if you constantly finding
yourself defending just bad,
like bad people.
And even if you're not one,
if you have,
mostly what I find myself doing is I'm
being supported by a very large number of
people and being,
um,
what would you call,
put on the spot in various
uncomfortable ways by a tiny,
noisy minority of let
radical collectivists.
So that's mostly I feel are
more mostly what I experienced.
So isn't it,
what side of history,
isn't it your buddies who says sacks
don't care about your feelings?
So that's how you feel.
I'm sorry,
that's not my intent here.
Uh,
but again,
that is self authoring.com
12 rules for life.
Uh,
uh,
Dr. Jordan Peterson tongs
for taking the time.
Um,
you know,
I listen man.
I mean you have,
you have your point of view
and I'll have mine and uh,
I mean there it is.
Hey,
if you liked this video,
subscribe.
But that doesn't really mean a whole lot
so you can hit the notification bell.
I know that that Schuyler was incredibly
unpleasant with Dr. Jordan Peterson.
I wanted to kick his ass,
so I get it.
Subscribe it.
The Notification Bell,
join my club or watch one of these other
videos that could be playing in a box
somewhere.
I it maybe youtube banded at this point.
Who knows?